on va tout de suite passer au témoin du
jour on va revenir sur l'affaire ari
habiton euh qui fait à nouveau parler
alors que l'humoriste remonte sur scène
après avoir été euh donc euh soupçonné
de viol par une jeune femme ça ne passe
pas pour nous toutes qui lutent contre
les violences sexuelles et sexistes le
collectif a demandé l'annulation de deux
de ses représentations à La Rochelle
alors où ça on est regardez pourtant il
a commencé ses dates de rodage à
rhabitant au mou à Tahiti sous les
acclamations du public
regardez regarde-mo
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma mèreappelle Mar ma sœur s'appelle
etess s'appelle
l on s'oublie pas à
bientôt merci d'être avec nous Myriam
Palomba on va revenir sur cette affaire
et merci à Lina benarmed d'être avec
nous militante nous tout merci beaucoup
d'être là alors myiam déjà on en est où
de cette affaire parce que justement
c'est là le le truc hein et c'est pour
ça parce que alors l'affaire a été
clôturée par les juges d'instruction
pour rappeler un petit peu les faits on
apprenait le le le 31 octobre 2021 que
har habitant était en garde à vue suite
à des accusations de viol d'une jeune
femme alors les fait remoné à la veille
cette jeune femme de 23 ans avec qui il
entretenait une relation épisodique
depuis 2 mois l'accuse en fait d'avoir
de l'avoir forcé à avoir un rapport
sexuel anal donc un rapport non consenti
et du coup suite suite à ça elle est
partie au commissariat faire une main
courante les enquêteurs ont estimé à
l'époque que son témoignage était assez
sérieux et ont décidait dès le lendemain
de d'aller chercher àih habitant et il y
a même une perquisition à ce moment-l
qui a été faite où des draps qui étaient
tachés de sang ont été trouvés et suite
à à ça le juge d'instruction a mis en
examen Harry habitant pour viol et il a
été placé sous contrôle judiciaire alors
euh il est revenu sur scène euh qui
produit son spectacle il a trouvé
facilement des des des alors c'est
toujours son producteur traditionnel
hein GT poulier qui qui le finance il y
a aussi alors moi je sais voilà que il y
a également des des des investisseurs
qui personnels des amis personnels d'aré
habitant très riches qui l'aide
également à produire son spectacle et
d'une manière générale il est à nouveau
soutenu par tout son entourage alors que
pendant pendant plusieurs mois il a été
tricard alors
euh il a écrit sur insta ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait plus ces nouvelles
et le 30 août dernier il a annoncé sur
son compte insta la fin de l'écriture de
son nouveau spectacle je ne me suis
jamais arrêté d'écrire tellement hâte de
vous retrouver pour mon nouveau
spectacle vous me manquez à un point que
les mot peine à exprimer euh voilà il a
encore tweeté tellement hâte de vous
retrouver voici quelques dates de rodage
bientôt d'autres à venir il a désactivé
les commentaires sous ses posts oui il a
désactivé les commentaires alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ça faisait
depuis le 30 octobre 2021 qu'il n'avait
rien posté et puis il a commencé à
reposter sur Instagram des messages
début août de l'année dernière et il a
même fait des stories qui ont été liké
par par des milliers des milliers de
personnes comment il va aujourd'hui ah
il va super bien d'accord comment vous
savez-vous parce que je le sais il va
super bien il est très très soulagé euh
de que cette que que l'enquête so on va
en parler dans un instant de l'enquête
oui je mais juste il il est il va bien
et comment va la la la plaignante la
plaignante elle est toujours traumatisée
elle se sent très très mal alors suite à
la clôturation de l'enquête elle avait
pensé du coup à porter plainte pour
violence aggravée sur sur conjoint sur
concubin mais finalement elle s'est
désisté et elle essae surtout de de
d'oublier toute cette histoire qui euh
qu' l'a beaucoup traumatisé euh ils ont
ils ont plus de contact tous les deux
hein après ils ont plus de contact plus
du tout de contact d'accord euh et donc
là aujourd'hui donc il a repris une vie
normale il a repris une vie normale he
on l'a vu dans la presse people on l'a
vu en vacances à
punakana on l'a vu à saint-tropé cet été
je sais aussi part qu'il est parti à Tel
Aviv euh récmentz dans une agence de
voyage vous êtes ah c'est VI c'est vrai
et donc ouais donc et donc ouais et donc
et donc voilà donc lui il il va il va
très bien il a repris sa petite vie et
et il est enfin voilà pour lui tout est
oublié al pourquoi tout est oublié
puisque le 19 juillet dernier la mise en
examen pour viol a été levée gilouou est
passé de mis en examen au statut
beaucoup plus favorable de témoins
assistés est-ce qu'on peut expliquer ça
à nos téléspectateurs sur
l'affaireabitant dont on aou mais en
examen ça veut dire qu'il y a des
indices graves et concordants qui font
accréditer au juges l'idée que vous
pourriez être jugé un jour
potentiellement coupable même si vous
êtes présumé innocent témoin à insister
ça allège beaucoup et là ça allège
tellement Cyril que on s'achemine vers
un nonlieu cette AFF faire il y aura un
nonlieu total donc comme effectivement
il y a pas de plainte encore là et il y
en aura sans doute pas pour des
violences et bien Harry habitant lui le
30 août s'est senti entre guillemets
galvanisé il a fait ce poste qui a
suscité beaucoup de remous j'ai écrit
mais là cette fois je reprends la scène
il a joué à Tahiti il a joué au Man et
donc là il prévoit de jouer à La
Rochelle alors les juges d'instruction
n'ont pas relevé d'indice grave ou
concordant non et il soulève quand même
que la présumée victime a un stress
post-traumatique indiscutable
applaignante ça veut dire que pour euou
mais mais mais ils n'ont pas relevé
d'indice grave pas du tout non non non
non il est il est il va êre blanchi dans
quoi c'est parce qu'en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que il y a eu un premier
rapport sexuel entre eux et visiblement
les les lésions traumatiques et les
saignements dont a été victime la
plaignante existait à la base lors de
ces premiers rapports et le deuxième en
fait les se enfin tout ce qu'ils ont
trouvé comme preuve n'a pas permis is de
de de prouver que ce deuxième rapport
sexuel avait été fait sous la contrainte
donc la juge d'instruction enfin les
juges d'instruction ont décidé comme ils
ont eu tous les deux ils ont été
confrontés plusieurs fois ensemble et
tous les deux ont quand même expliqué ce
qui s'était passé qu'ils avaient bien eu
effectivement de rapports sexuels la
juge même si elle reconnaît
effectivement le traumatisme de la
victime que ça c'est indiscutable ils
estiment que bah c'est c'est pas assez
probant pour pour aller sur des
accusations de viol d'autant plus que
Harry habitant a apporté beaucoup de
témoignages d'anciennes petites amies
qui disent que c'est un un amant très
respectueux alors justement les
expertises psychiatriques n'ont pas
révélé d'éléments de personnalité en
faveur d'une sexualité déviante ou de
pulsion sexuelle agressive he g donc ça
c'est ce qui c'est le rapport absolument
les rapports d'expertise lui ont été
globalement très favorables sauf le
rapport médical qui était très précis la
victime a eu de nombreux jours d'ITT la
plignante pardon J dit été et il y a des
signes destranglements il y a voilà il y
a un rapport médical circonstancié mais
qui n'est pas incompatible avec un
éventuel rapport consenti alors parce
que depuis sa mise en quand il avait été
mise en examen il s'était vu retirer son
rôle dans la fiction en cours de
tournage l'homme de nos vies réalisé par
Frédéric Bert pour M6 il devait remonter
sur scène quelques mois après voilà et
toutes les dates avaient été reporté ou
annulé et bien sûr il avait été
complètement écarté de la promo du film
qu'est-ce qu'on a tous fait au bon Dieu
comment on fait dans ces cas-là parce
que mine de rien là c'est cétait un mon
est terrible pour lui c'était un manque
à gagner bon heureusement il avait
quelques économies il avait des amis
assez riches qui l'ont aidé
financièrement il a aussi changé
d'appartement parce que voilà l'autre
était avait des charges trop importantes
pour lui après il avait quand même pas
mal d'économie sa femme enfin sa
compagne travaille alors il est resté
d'ailleurs sa compagne l'a pas lâché he
non sa compagne l' pas lâché elle a été
l'un des des principal soutien c'est une
très belle preuve d'amour he oui c'est
une belle preuve d'amour après voilà
enfin ce qui ce qu' en résulte quand
même c'est que malgré tout il y a il y
avait il y a eu tromperie dans
l'histoire mais elle ne l'a elle ne l'a
pas lâché effectivement alors le
problème pour lui c'est que lors de ces
spectacles il y a des militantes nous
toutes notamment qui sont devant c'est
devant devant devant c'est les salles de
spectacle et qui veulent interdire le
spectacle c'est ça oui c'est ça il y a y
a le il y a un collectif qui veut qui
veut le faire Atir al ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'il a fait déjà une
première une première représentation à
Tahiti qui s'est extrêmement bien passé
il a été acclamé il y en a une autre au
Man qui qui qui s'est très bien passé là
le 2 octobre dernier et il y a deux
dates à La Rochelle le 16 et le le 16ors
10 il a le 10 et le 11 à La Rochelle
mais il y a un communiqué du comité
local nous tout qui vient faire barrage
qui dit en effet proposer le devant de
la scène à des agresseurs présumés
revient à se porter caution d'actes
intolérable et contribue activement à
l'impunité qui aujourd'hui la règle
lorsque les accusations visent des
hommes célèbres ou de pouvoir il ne
s'agit pas bien sûr de se substituer à
la justice parfois impuissante mais de
cesser d'alimenter le mépris à l'égard
des victimes de violence en offrant une
visibilité positive à des agresseurs
potentiels justement merci d'être avec
nous Lena merci beaucoup Lena quand le
19 juillet dernier on apprend que la
mise en examen pour viol a été levée euh
pour vous euh il ne doit pas quand même
remonter sur scène alors en fait ça n'a
rien surprenant qu'il n'y a pas de
condamnation et cetera parce Queen fait
en France c'est la majorité des cas pour
les femmes victimes de violence sexuelle
c'est extrêmement dur et très difficile
de faire prouver un viol quand il n'y a
pas de témoins c'est parole contre
parole en fait donc en fait faire le
choix de programmer un artiste qui est
mis en cause pour viol c'est en fait à
ce moment-là c'est prendre le parti de
de l'agresseur du potentiel agresseur au
lieu plutôt que de ne pas se positionner
en fait cette ce choix est une prise de
position donc Lena pour vous il il doit
plus travailler plus faire son m en fait
en fait en fait le c'est les les les
salles ont le choix de programmer des
artistes c'est-à-dire qu'ils font le
choix de mettre en en lumière cet
homme-l C cet homme mis en cause pour
viol je me fais l'avocat de du diable
entre Guill moi je suis pas là pour me
soucier de sa carrière ce soir
c'estàdire moi c'est pas mon problème
moi moi je suis là
pour moi je parle au nom des des patrons
de de de théâtre eux ils se disent le 19
juillet dernier la mise en examen pour
viol a été levée donc nous on on on on
suit la justice donc forcément on peut
programmer cet artiste il avait pas fait
avant Gill c'est ça qui le patron de la
salle de La Rochelle a dit texto nous ne
sommes pas des juges la justice a fait
son boulot il n'est plus mis en examen
je suis programmateur disIl et j'essaie
d'être neutre donc je programme ça
d'être neutre donc il manque d'artistes
il manque d'artistes qui ne sont pas mis
en cause pour viol on choisit à partir
du moment où on on choisit cet artiste
en connaissance de cause c'est-à-dire
que parmi mais tous les artistes qui
existent ont fait le choix de se
positionner et on silenci c'est-à-dire
qu'on ça veut dire exactement vous le
dites on n'est pas la justice donc
c'està dire qu'on on peut pas exactement
on n'est pas la justice mais par contre
on a une responsabilité collective dans
une a postmou on a pris conscience en
fait de de de l'ampleur des violences
sexit sexuelle on a énormément entendu
parler on a entendu la parole des femmes
et pas parce qu'on a voulu l'entendre
mais par parce qu'elles se sont imposé à
un moment donné dans le débat dans
l'espace public elles ont parlé on les a
entendu aujourd'hui la conséquence de
tout ça c'est que il y a une de une
deuxième étape on a pris conscience de
de l'ampleur de ces violences la
deuxième étape c'est de se
responsabiliser collectivement de dire
moi dans ma vie professionnelle dans ma
vie personnelle je fais le choix de ne
pas promouvoir des hommes qui seraient
potentiellement des violeurs donc
c'est-à-dire que dans ma vie personnelle
si demain j'ai un ami qui est accusé de
viol et ben je ne suis plus il est pas
accusé parce que la justice il a été mis
en cause il a été mis en cause mais il
n'est pas innocenté
inoc aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est
innocenté on s'achemine vers un nonlieu
le nonlie va
être c'est même pas sûr qu'il y a un
nonlieu ou cluré termin il est blanchi
VO donc il est est-ce qu'il est
blanchi aux yeux de la justice est qu'il
est blanch exonéré totalement des
accusations de viol voilà c'est pas une
opinion c'est un fait ça
donc non non il y a pas de non lieu
juridiquement il y a pas on n
pas jou pas sur les mots l'action peut
s'éteindre sans qu'il y ait
prononce le N lieu donc l'action peut
s'éindre mec est-ce qu'il est blanchi ou
pas la question est simple au la justice
il a violé personne exactement voilà
merci Géral d'être clair parce que là
c'est c'est c'est on est on est au yeux
de la justice en France il y a 1 % des
vleurs qui sont condamnés donc aux yeux
de la justice il y a il y a pas de
violence oui mais alors Géraldine tu non
moi je comprends évidemment votre combat
et je pense effectivement que la
libération de la parole des femmes était
très était très important et nécessaire
mais pardonnez-moi là dans ce cas-là le
problème c'est que on soit il l'a violé
soit il l'a pas violé c'est
malheureusement assez binaire donc après
vous pouvez dire vous pouvez dire bah en
fait oui mais on sait pas en fait vous
n'avez pas confiance en la justice mais
ça c'est un autre problème mais il a le
droit quand même réalité c'est une
réalité oui mais alors à ce momentlà
qu'est-ce que vous dites parce je sais
pas par exemple Luc Besson il a eu un
nonlieu donc il a pas le droit de faire
des films Benjamin mi il a eu un nonlieu
donc il a pas le droit de jouer au foot
on moi je veux pas le voir ben oui mais
à ce moment-là mais vous pouvez pas
empêcher les gens d'aller les voir s'ils
ont envie de le voir pas SP je vous
oblige pas aller
voir donc ça veut dire on fait on fait
semblant d'accueillir la parole des
femmes et quand on on peut mettre en
lumière des hommes que ces mêmes femmes
ont accusé on va les acclamer mais ils
ont été blanchis en fait il y a des
nonlieux mais ça ne veut pas dire
innocent c'est là la différence ça ne
veut pas dire innocent donc la justice
son
quoi système c'est vous qui allez
donner la justice et vous toi tuas le
droit de jouer toi tuas pas le droit de
jouer absolument pas je parle de
responsabilité collective d'entendre la
parole des femmes donc c'està-dire
d'agir c'està-dire agir en consé on l'
entendu puisend on fait
rien vous ent campagn qui sont venus
dans le dans le prtoir pour dire com la
justice mademoiselle com rendez compte
que vous allez au-delà de la justice en
fait non justement je ne me subs dit
vous substituez pas à la justice mais en
fait je voudrais juste dire une chose il
y a la morale et puis il y a la justice
la morale d'un point de vue moral vous
pouvez considérer que ça vous heurte et
que c'est immoral qu'il remonte sur
scène mais la justice c'est la justice
si la procédure séteint je termine si la
procédure s'éteint il est officiellement
blanchi par la société ce qui nous un
c'est quand même des règles la règle
c'est la justice il y a des juges qui se
sont posés des questions qui ont enquêté
qui ont qui ont enrichi leur dossier qui
ont qui ont mené des interrogatoires ça
fait plusieurs mois que ça dure et au
final ils en arrivent à la conclusion
qu'il ne alors c'est peut-être très
heurtant pour un certain nombre de
femmes qui savent qui qu'elles ont été
agressé sexuellement et donc ça je peux
le comprendre mais reconnaissez que ça
relève de la morale là vous allez plus
loin une deuxième justice en fait que
vous votre justice supplante la vraie
justice aujourd'hui les personnes
personnes qui vont voir son spectacle
c'est pas des juges c'est la société en
c'est c'est les personnes qui composent
cette société donc aujourd'hui si demain
les personnes qui qui composent cette
société ont un rôle à jouer et ben c'est
en tant que citoyen et citoyenne
qu'elles doivent agir donc demain et
aujourd'hui il y a il y a des façons de
se mobiliser et çaen est une parce que
en France quand on a du mal à avoir une
justice à avoir du mal à se faire
entendre et ben c'est un moyen comme un
autre de faire exister nos voix qui sont
constamment silenciés constamment remis
en question ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais madame le spectacle de La
Rochelle il y a de jours le premier jour
le mardi c'est complet les gens ont
acheté leur place qu'est-ce que vous
leur dites alors vous dites vous n'avez
pas le droit d'acheter une place il ne
peut plus jouer quelle est votre
position là aux yeux de la justice il a
été blanchi vous avez oui
ou il n'est plus poursuivi du tout pour
viol faut être clair et bien ce jour-là
il y aura des militantes n tout qui
attendront les les personnes devant
devant la salle pour pour juste les
informer en fait donc c'est-à-dire
allez-y en connaissance de
cause et c'est pour ça qu'à ce momentl
pas forcément c'est pour ça que à ce
moment-là on parle de responsabilité en
tant
qu'individu donc ça veut dire mais
justement on on en parle juste c'est on
en parle juste et c'est quand qu'on a vu
pour le coup que vous manifestiez devant
une salle de spectacle pour dire voilà
ce que nous on pense pourquoi pas c'est
pas ce que nous on pense ce sont les
faits qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé est-ce que vous êtes en
accordveéciation des faits mademoiselle
c'est pas les faits les faits ils ont
été il y a des juges qui décident faes
c'est c'est vous vous interprétez des
faits Guillaume question il y a deux
choses qui me gêne c'est que vous
sousentendez qu'à partir d'un du moment
où où un homme est accusé il est
forcément coupable et ensuite que vous
donnez le pouvoir même si je ne minimise
pas du tout la gravité des agressions
sexuelles mais donc à n'importe qui
potentiellement de briser une carrière
sur la base de simples accusations on
les voit les carrières brisées hein non
mais oui c'est ce que vous voulez vous
lu souitez pendant ans pendant 2
ans alors alors ce qui se passe c'est
que on on ne on ne justement quand on en
fait on ne met pas en en doute la
présomption d'innocence tout ce qu'on
fait c'est entendre la parole des
victimes et en fait c'est c'est c'est
c'est jamais équilibré en fait
c'est-à-dire que quand on parle de
présomption d'innocence et ben c'est
toujours pour remettre en cause la
parole de la victime et c'est jamais
cette parole qui est entendu parce qu'on
parle de priseempon d'innocence donc
c'est c'est pas équitable Lena l l Lena
juste donc si vous nous rejoignez voilà
c'est Elena qui est avec nous elle
représente nous toutes on embrasse
d'ailleurs nous toutes viennent souvent
nous voir ici et c'est vrai que voilà ce
que vous êtes en train de dire vous pour
résumer c'est elle ne se substitue pas à
la justice le collectif nous toutes veut
pour l'instant aller devant les salles
de spectacles où Harry habitant joue
pour informer c'est ça c'est ça ça en
fait d'ailleurs en fait il y a même une
une salle de spectacle qui a déjà pris
l'initiative cet été quand l'homme P il
a été accusé de viol ils ont décidé de
le
déprogrammer il y a rien qui les
obligait à le faire mais c'était par
responsab enfin c'est par responsabilité
c'est aussi par peur du mauvais buzz
aussi Lenard on va pas se mentir mais et
Ben et ben peu importe te les raisons
aujourd'hui le principal c'est c'est de
créer un mouvement c'est de créer un
mouvement de responsabilisation et
encore je vais le répéter ce mot mais
c'est en fait les violences sexuelles
elles nous concernent toutes et tous
donc c'estàd que tout le monde est est
capable d'agir et et puis que des
programmeurs le comprennent c'est une
bonne chose juste Lena pour vous Harry
habitant il doit pas être sur scène plus
jamais plus jamais non donc même si la
justice le 19 juillet en tout en tout
cas même siil est produit un choix c'est
un choix déclaré innocent il doit plus
monter sur scène il doit faire un autre
métier en fait en fait le le faire le
choix de le programmer c'est c'est c'est
volontaire c'est-à-dire que c'est
c'est-à-dire que non mais c'est parce
queil y a des gens qui veulent qu'il
exerce son métier aussi parce que ils
ont attendu la décision de justice ils
nont pas programmé avant avant la
décision de justice personne ça veut
dire à l'instant où où on dit en fait on
ne sait pas parce que du coup au final
on on ne pourra jamais savoir c'est on
saute on saute sur l'occasion fait
confiance à la
justice mais quand on a des nonlieux et
cetera c'est c'est c'est exactement ce
qui se passe
justement je ne dis pas il est
condamné autre chose alors justice qui
fonctionne vous pouvez pas vous
substituer comme ça la décision la
justice c'est ce qui nous on demande une
justice qui fonctionne je ne demande pas
être la justice J et là c'est c'est la
même chose il a il la justice a jugé
qu'il n'avait pas fauté vous pouvez pas
lui détruire sa carrière en fait on en
revient toujours à la même chose pour
mettre tout le monde d'accord par
exemple ce soir et ben il faudrait que
la justice soit modifiée et qu'elle soit
vraiment plus juste et qu'elle fasse son
son rôle tout
simpement parle pas sur ce cas
particulier mais tous les soirs à chaque
fois on dit non mais la justice à de
vitess la justice c'est pas possible si
on arrê de dire ça et qu'on sera qu'on
légitimera tous la justice et ben on
serait pas en TR de
parler d'accord avec ça si je peuxre
parce la justice n'a pas dit qu'il était
elle a dit qu'il n'y avait pas de preuve
suffisamment caractérisé pour prouver
oui mais non mais c'est pas la même
chose parce qu'ils ont reconnu quand
même le caractère post traumatique de la
victime c'est juste que comme ils
avaient une relation qui a eu un premier
rapport sexuel ils sont incapables de
prouver ce viol mais à aucun moment ils
ont dit que ce viol n'avait pas existé
c'est différent il y a pas de preuve
suffisamment caractérisé pour pouvoir
continuer une mise en examen et un
renvoi devant le tribunal merci l
d'avoir la exp vot pointue merci à tous
tout de suite c'est Laura sur C
spectacle très fort
merci